a major terrorist attack in Barcelona
the president reacts the media
overreaction we talk about nothing but
Confederate statues all the time forever
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the venture
Pierrot show all rights have a lot to
get you today as always very busy news
week honestly I'm just glad that it's
practic but before we get to any of the
things that I just mentioned first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Lincoln so this is one of my
favorite apps this is something you put
on your phone and what it allows you to
do is basically go through a book in 15
minutes no I don't mean that it's going
to read the entire 500 page book to you
at ten times speed what I mean is that
it sums up the main points of a book in
15 minutes or less they call them blinks
and this allows you you have an
hour-long drive you can go through the
main points in four books so this means
that you're just getting nothing but
information for like me if you're an
information junkie if you feel like you
need to mainline that feed right into
your brain that's what blinka is for and
right now blink Asst bli nki st.com
slash been you do that you get a free
trial or three months off your yearly
plan now again what they do is they take
popular books books that you know it's
book a why nations fail with great book
600 pages takes you two weeks to read if
you're a fast reader instead you get the
entire main points of the book in 15
minutes with blinkers and that's great
because if you read the 600 page book a
month later all you're going to remember
is 15 minutes worth of material if
you're lucky anyway so that's what blink
astiz for blink is calm /femme is a
special offer for our audience again if
you use flash Ben right now you get a
free trial or three months off your
yearly plan when you join today so you
can go through these bite-sized pieces
of information quickly and they have all
these popular books if you're into
finance they have things like Rich Dad
Poor Dad they have a great book called
flow which is all about thinking better
you know all of these books are
available in 15 minutes or less
over at blink accom so go check out
blink is calm use that promo code Ben
blink is calm slash Ben and you get your
free trial or three months off your
membership when you get your yearly
membership okay so lots to get to
obviously the biggest story of the day
is not what the media are saying is the
biggest story of the day the media want
to focus on Confederate monuments
statues they've been up for 50 years or
20 years or
50 years but the real issue yesterday's
that there was a major terrorist attack
in Barcelona so for people who missed it
this is a major Isis planned cell
apparently according to CNN the
perpetrators of the terror attacks in
Barcelona and came Broyles originally
planned to use explosive devices to read
greater devastation but were apparently
thwarted because their materials
detonated prematurely police said Friday
the house in Elkin are south of
Barcelona was destroyed in a blast on
Wednesday night hours before one
attacker mowed down dozens of people in
the heart of Barcelona killing 13 a
group of five attackers then drove into
pedestrians in the town of Cambridge
killing one in the early hours of Friday
Catalan police chief jose luis de perro
told reporters explosives were found in
the Alcantara property and the police
are working on the hypothesis that these
attacks were being prepared in that
house the revelations pointed to an
alarming conclusion that authorities
knew nothing of an advanced plot to
mount the spectacular terror attack
until that accidental explosion at the
perpetrators base and despite the
eye-catching setback terrorists also
managed to carry out to further
improvised attacks without impediment so
four people have been arrested them been
arrested one of them now scan our three
and repo three were Moroccan citizens
another was Spanish they ranged in age
from 21 to 34 none was on the radar for
terrorism all were apparently Muslim
Spain's Prime Minister Mariano Rajoy
labeled the Barcelona attack jihadi
terrorism which is a perfect description
now Hoy's government has declared three
days of mourning across Spain the Isis
media wing has said that the Barcelona
attackers were soldiers of Isis but
stopped short of saying that they took
responsibility for the attack probably
because it was a botched attack so
naturally this would demand a unified
response from the West right this would
be the time when you expected West to
renew its determination to stamp out
Isis to signal solidarity and president
from actually tried to do that initially
president Trump initially goes on
Twitter and he says that he is going to
stand with the people of Barcelona the
people of Spain will have to stand
together and then he tweets out he
tweets out study what general perishing
of the United States did to terrorists
one caught there was no more radical to
Islamic terror for 35 years this is the
problem with Trump's run on mouth this
is a problem with a brain that has no
filter ok what he just did is he
polarized the response so instead of
everybody being unified Isis bad let's
kill them all instead in this suite he
endorses fictitious history he endorses
a fictitious history that includes a war
crime and he slanders General Pershing
because what is he exactly talking about
what Trump is actually talking about
here is a legend wherein supposedly
general perishing Trump has told this
story before he said that that that
perishing was a rough guy and during the
moral rebellion in the Philippines from
1899 to 1913 perishing served as
governor between 1909 and 1913 perishing
quote 50 terrorists who did tremendous
damage and he took the 50 terrorists and
he took 50 men and 50 bullets and pig's
blood you heard about that he took 50
bullets and dipped them in pig's blood
he had his men load up their rifles and
he lined up the 50 people and they shot
49 of those people and the 50th person
he said you go back to your people and
you tell them what happened ok so that
didn't actually happen now to be fair to
President from general perishing
apparently at one that one diplomatic
meeting brought the head of a pig
apparently tomorrow's were very very
upset with pork and apparently there
were reports that there were members of
the American the American
counterterrorism unit who had taken
terrorists and wrapped them and pig
skins and buried them or buried them
with pigs
so perishing had used the who demented
those religious aversions and pigs
against them but there's no evidence
that he did what Trump said he did so
what this did is it allowed the media to
escape the broader issue which is
radical Islamic terror and the media of
course did this media we're looking for
an excuse not to talk about jihadi
terror so they could stay on Trump so
they could stay on what happened in
charlottesville instead of swiveling to
cover what is a significantly more
deadly terror attack in Spain this is
not - didn't this is not - you know make
light of what happened in child still at
all but just in pure numbers terms what
happened in Spain is a significantly
more serious terror attack than what
happened in charlottesville but the
media spends all day yesterday
continuing to talk about Charlottesville
and talking about this suite which is
what they wanted to do in fact Wolf
Blitzer made some of the stupidest
comments I've ever seen on CNN here is
Wolf Blitzer as this was unfolding
trying to suggest and maybe just maybe
what happened in Barcelona was a copycat
attack or something because of
Charlotte's know what now those shared
tactics that should be alarming
yeah and there will be questions about
copycats there will be questions if what
happened in Barcelona was at all at all
a copycat version of what happened
in Charlottesville Virginia even though
there may be different characters
different political ambitions they use
the same the same killing device a
vehicle going at high speed into a group
a large group of pedestrians and as the
local police are saying at least one
person is not able to earn anything in
order to avoid talking about the spate
of jihadi terror and it has been trucked
here right we've had that in Nice we had
that in Berlin with the attack on the
Christmas market in Berlin in Jerusalem
you've had this multiple times people
using trucks is ramming vehicles in
order to murder people
but wolf Blitzer's first instinct is to
try and connect this back to Charlotte
Ville because the media would like to
continue talking about Charlotte's ville
and that's just asinine
okay the general the general perishing
comments from from are stupid they're
they're a waste of time they're waste of
effort they undermine our ability to get
along with with some of our Muslim
allies you know none of this is good but
to suggest that has any newest
charlottesville or that that's the main
issue here Trump the one thing you can
say about Trump and he certainly has
done this he has unleashed the military
against Isis the one-third of all
territory taken against Isis over the
last seven eight years has been during
the Trump administration Trump is
utterly untied the hands of the military
in the fight against Isis and it's been
actually creating some significant
results to focus in on Trump stupid
tweet and or to focus in on
Charlottesville in the aftermath of this
attack just demonstrates where the media
wants to put their attention it's
obvious where the media wants to put
their attention you know it's amazing if
you think about what happened in
Charlottesville there should be a spate
of propositions that every one of good
heart and good mind can agree on
okay these are very basic propositions
neo Nazis bad white supremacism bad all
right white nationalism bad right all
those things bad communism bad anarchism
bad violence at non-violent rallies bad
right all of these things I think we
should all be able to agree on is
they're not difficult and yet somehow
we've turned this into a polarized
political debate I think that if you had
just described the things I just said I
think you would get 95 percent of
America
to agree on those things right communism
bad does not seem particularly
controversial to me and Tifa starting
violence at particular rallies all
across the country a bad thing that's
not what about ISM that's just a fact
okay what about ISM would suggest that
I'm saying that it's okay for the
neo-nazis in Charlotte so that's what
they did I'm not saying that at all in
fact I've been the probably the harshest
or one of the harshest condemned the
unite the right rally in Charlottesville
and they all right overall white
supremacism bad I think the ninety five
percent of Americans agree with that
general proposition and yet somehow this
has turned into a polarized political
debate and it's turned into a polarized
political debate because all of the
actors wanted to be a polarized
political debate the left want to
proclaim that there are a bunch of
people out there who are racist because
American society is racist Trump wants
to claim that the entire left wants
America to be called racist so that he
can fight back against this right this
is Steve Bam and said it's clearly okay
this is not conjecture Steve baman said
that in an interview at The New York
Times please let the left continue to
engage in identity politics and that's
only going to help us let them talk
about tearing down Confederate statutes
that's only going to help us the left
thinks it's winning the Confederate
statue argument the right thing since
winning the Confederate statue argument
Trump thinks he's winning the
Confederate statue argument and
meanwhile the broad agreement that most
of us have on these issues is gone the
broad agreement is gone even though the
Confederate statues I think there's
broad agreement that people in New York
don't have a lot to say about
Confederate statues in South Carolina
and if the mayor of if the mayor the
elected mayor of Charlotte's Hill
decides that he wants to remove a robert
e lee statue he's an elected mayor
that's his responsibility he can do that
i may disagree with the decision but i
really don't have a lot of say in that
particular decision i believe in
localism particularly when it comes to
cultural historical issues like this one
i think there's broad agreement on all
of this but you can see that there's an
attempt to polarize the country the left
wants people to believe that america is
a deeply racist place and so what
they're attempting to say is that anyone
who wants to keep the confederate
statues up must be a racist I was on CNN
last night with Don Lemon and a couple
of other folks including Keith Boykin
who's a Democratic strategist and Keith
Boykin openly said anyone who wants to
keep the the statues up of Confederate
memorials is a racist or is a white
supremacist
Don Lemon virgin on that night I
actually call them out on it I
questioned him on any backed off of it
but this is
one of the things that's really nasty
and then on the Trump side you have a
bunch of people like Pat Buchanan or out
there almost overtly declare and support
for white supremacism because they think
they have to do that in order to fight
the left or because they actually
believe it and we'll get to all of this
in just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at USC CA
you would do virtually anything to keep
it your family safe and that's exactly
what Gary gross was thinking when two
intruders broke into a Cincinnati home
last week his wife his infant son they
were sleeping in a back room and Gary
grabbed a hammer and confronted strange
men when they were in his house he was
at number two two one he grabbed his gun
he shot the men before they could go any
further he was lucky that he was
prepared but you may not be prepared and
that's why you need to talk to my
friends over the u.s. CCA
you need to have the u.s. CCA in your
corner when you have to do the
unthinkable like pull the trigger in a
bad situation
does it defend my family now calm to see
the world-class training and resources
as well as their invaluable self-defense
coverage that self-defense coverage
means that if somebody comes in your
house and you have to shoot them then
you're not going to spend the next three
years of your life spending money on
lawyers so that you can defend yourself
as an added bonus when you activate your
membership you get a free entry right
now to win today's gun they give away a
gun today so you can be prepared to
defend yourself and your loved ones you
can just go over and sign up defend my
family now.com against defend my family
now can they provide you the training
the resources and maybe if you're lucky
the gun at defend my family now calm the
US CCA's doing wonderful work they are
one of our favorite endorsers okay so
speaking of leftist overreaction again
the left always has to overstuff it's so
funny
whenever the left does something bad
like whenever there's a leftist who
shoots up a bunch of Congress people and
it's out of the news in three days
because the media don't want to talk
about it anymore then what they do is
they accuse the right of overreach oh
the rights overreaching oh the right is
speaking too much about this random
Barcelona attacks you'll have President
Trump say something about perishing and
all of the media coverage will be about
the perishing comments not about the
actual terror attack well the left is
really they are the kings and queens of
overreaction I mean they really are
amazing at this so for example New
York's subway system the again I don't
know what any of the test to do with
what just happened in Charlottesville
but there is there a bunch of tiles in
the New York subway system that look
kind of like a confederate flag it will
kind of like a confederate flag this is
what they look like
there's a debate over what this was
supposed to be one side says that there
was a New York Times editor who's from
the south and so when they built this
particular subway station they put the
symbol in there as an homage to the no
Maj to the person who was from the New
York Times there's another the MTA says
it's not about a confederate flag at all
it was supposed to be the crossroads of
the world or whatever it is it kind of
looks like a confederate flag now is
Richard Spencer like marching around
there in a torchlight parade are we
going to get are we going to get Chris
Cantwell rallying down there for the
freakin subway tiles like the biggest
problem in New York right now the subway
system sucks okay maybe they've been
running late a lot of somebody's broken
it smells like urine all the time and
now they're worried about what is this
there's got to be about twenty five
tiles
remian is about twenty five tiles in the
subway station and this is what they're
deeply concerned about is getting rid of
these subway tiles again the
overreaction is astonishing the
overreach by the left is astonishing
you're seeing it to the extreme a
Democratic lawmaker from Missouri
she actually posted on her Facebook page
that she hoped that Trump would die
right it's pretty amazing so this is
this you know this lady posted to
Facebook that she hoped that Trump would
be assassinated right so this guy said
damn now I'll probably get a visit from
the Secret Service he said I wonder what
my cousin is thinking now he's on Trump
Secret Service detail you have to sign
up for six years he did his first four
with Obama it has to to go with this
idiot but what I believe are most it
earlier I believe will happen soon or
not later and Maria Chapelle module who
is a state legislator in Missouri
she posted back no I will I hope Trump
is assassinated I hope Trump is
assassinated now should she lose her job
over that yes she should okay you should
lose your job over that when you are an
elected official and you hope for the
assassination of your political opponent
then you should lose your job over that
imagine if the situation reverse and it
had been some Republican legislator
saying that about Obama how fast would
his job be gone
almost immediately instead Chappelle
medalled says I didn't mean what I put
up absolutely not I was very frustrated
it was in response to the concerns that
I'm hearing from residents of st. Louis
I've deleted it and it should have been
deleted but there is something way more
important we should be talking about
well no it seems to me that this is a
pretty important thing to be talking
about the leftist embrace of violence
the leftist overreaction and embrace of
violence is a dangerous thing it's an
actual dangerous thing
the Michael Eric Dyson who is on the
news all the time professor I believe at
Georgetown and Michael Eric Dyson he
comes out and he openly endorses auntie
pho which is a violent far left group
that has engaged in violence against
normal citizens in places ranging from
Sacramento to Seattle to Portland here's
Michael Eric Dyson saying and he was
wonderful now the people that we claim
black lives matter
the Antipa movement and talk are
interested in preserving the fabric of
America mr. Miller says again that there
was violence there but the problem is to
equate the violence in reaction against
bigotry with the bigotry itself is to
misunderstand the fact that when you go
to cancer treatment the radiation is
tough treatment but it is meant to
remove the cancer so what he fails to
understand and what the president
especially fails to understand is that
you are complicit with the worst
currents of bigotry in this country when
you try to draw a false equivalence
between secessionists and racists and
Confederate defenders and bigots and
neo-nazis and african-american and white
people and others who have defended the
right of this nation to really seek a
path of healing so yeah once their aim
is so wrong when he says the way to
fight cancer is with radiation okay I
agree that that we all right is a cancer
I agree the white supremacism is a
cancer but it's not a cancer that's
going to require surgery it's not a
cancer that kills the patient it really
isn't
I mean it's a very minut group of people
who are awful and evil but you don't
actually get to act in violence against
them saying there are cancer in sort of
a in sort of a generic there are harms
the body politic sense that that's
that's true but if you're saying they're
deadly that's not true okay if you're
saying that they are actually out there
killing people you know then you'll have
to point me to the ones who are actually
out there killing people and then I
would say let's let the police kill them
not you need n peopie out there beating
the crap out of them with clubs and
sticks and this is a problem because if
you have and talking about this all week
if you have a violent movement on the
Left that's being justified by the
mainstream left in response to the
alt-right and the alt-right is not
actually acting violently at these
rallies then
problem on your hands okay and if y'all
right is acting violently that's why we
have police in this country we don't
need groups of armed people going around
beating each other up it's not good for
the country but the West is embracing
all of this and it's it's really amazing
how the left's overreach is actually
making Trump appear better the left
overreach again that they're so stupid
the people on the far left that they
don't understand that if they would just
tell the truth about what happened this
week they would win instead they have to
go ten degrees further than that they
have to they have to go exponential in a
situation that requires a solid and a
proportionate response they the covers
from The Economist in The New Yorker are
not going to be helpful to the left
cause either so The New Yorker has a
cover of Trump on a boat blowing into
the sail and the sail looks like a Ku
Klux Klan hat and The Economist has a
cover up from shouting into a clue KKK
hood that looks like a loudspeaker now
this sort of thing is just going to lead
a lot of Trump supporters to think that
he's being unfairly maligned since Trump
did in fact actually condemn the KKK I
mean that's one of the things he
actually did do during the rendering the
during his his Tuesday crazy press
conference there's a lot of other things
that I thought were terrible but he did
say that he condemned the KKK so for
them to use the KKK hood as sort of the
symbol of what he's doing I understand
it's art but it's also art that is not
geared toward helping the conversation
particularly much what is doing the same
thing on this Confederate statue issues
so as I mentioned there's this attempt
by the left to suggest now that we must
talk about Confederate statues because
Richard Spencer and the alt-right and
the unite the right rally decided to
rally around robert e lee statue so now
we're going to have a big broad national
conversation about confederate statues
and donald trump said that we ought to
we ought to think about whether there's
a limiting principle basically we ought
to think whether the people who want to
get rid of the LEAs statues also want to
get rid of the washington statutes and
people on the left would know that's
crazy that's not true Keith Boykin said
that to me last night on CNN he says no
I think that there's a distinction
between these statues in Washington
statues I fully agree by the way but
CNN's Angelo ride did not and I called
her out last night on CNN for saying
this she was fully on board with the
idea that Washington and Jefferson
statues have to come down American
history is not all glorious and even
though I love John to death I couldn't
disagree more about George Washington
George Washington was a slave owner and
we need to call slave owners out for
what they are whether we think they were
protecting American freedom or not he
wasn't protecting my freedom I wasn't
someone who my ancestors weren't deemed
human beings to him and so to me I don't
care if it's a George Washington statue
or at Thomas Jefferson statue or a
robert e lee statue they all need to
come down there is a way that we can
recognize or generator now I'm not
fitting into white supremacy I'm calling
out white supremacy for what it is and
sometimes what it is John our blind
spots sometimes what it is is not
acknowledging that this country was
built upon a very violent past that
resulted in death and the raping and the
killing of my ancestors so I'm not going
to I'm not going to allow us to say that
it's okay for a robert e lee but not a
george y occasion was running on that
and Trump was right okay there is a
portion of the hard left that wants all
of those statues to come down al
Sharpton in absolute disgusting
race-baiting anti-semite he said the
same thing yesterday about the Jefferson
Memorial like Al Sharpton gets to be the
judge of bad symbolism al Sharpton was
was involved in incitement of riots in
1991 in Crown Heights ending with the
murder of an Orthodox Jew he was
involved in the Freddie's fashion Mart
debacle later that decade in which a
bunch of people were killed after
somebody set fire to a store that al
Sharpton was railing about that guy had
attended now Sharpton rally where he was
railing about white interlopers in in
the inner city
al Sharpton nonetheless here he is
saying the Thomas Jefferson he says that
we should blow up the Jefferson Memorial
I mean this is crazy this is not some
kind of removed discussion from us our
families were victims of this certainly
they ought to be there for everybody
associated with slavery in terms of any
public monument to them when you look at
the fact that public monuments are
supported by public funds
you're asking me to subsidize the engine
or Jefferson had slaves then and I would
repeat that the public should not be
paying up whole somebody who has had
that kind of background okay so there is
you know again the left's overreach here
is actually driving people into the arms
of the right into the arms of people who
I think are pretty
gross like Pat Buchanan Pat Buchanan has
been a quasi closeted white supremacist
for a long time he's been an anti-semite
for a long time
in 2005 he suggested the West should
never have gone to war with Hitler in
2006 he wrote the foreword to a book by
an actual white supremacist named Sam
Francis his magazine the American
conservative he co-founded with a guy
named taki Theodore Coppola who called
himself swathi some anti-semite a
William F Buckley said that that
Buchanan's views were answered medical
today Buchanan has a full-on column
basically the mirror image of what you
saw from Angela right there on CNN right
the mirror image so the Angela rice says
that Washington can't be distinguished
from Lee and then Pat Buchanan says the
same thing he says Washington can't be
distinguished formally and that's why we
should leave the status of the leaf
statues up because white supremacism is
actually not a horrible thing white
supremacism is not an actual horrible
thing so let me give you a portion from
this column because I think that it
demonstrates the the way that the
radical left and the radical right you
know pappi can't and the paleo
conservative right and not all paleo
conservatives are be Canaanites but
Buchanan's win of the of the of the
Republican Party how they have a common
view of American history that are that
are just basically the photo negatives
one another so Angela rice has a white
supremacist history so it's bad and
Buchanan says it's a white supremacist
history so it's good right there's
actually from his column tonight a
syndicated column another term applied
to the unite the right gathering in
Charlottesville is that they are white
supremacist a mortal sin to modernity
but here we encounter an even greater
problem looking back over the history of
a Western civilization which we call
great were not the explorers who came
out of Spain Portugal France Holland and
England all white supremacists they
conquered in the name of the mother
countries all the land they discovered
imposed their rules upon indigenous
peoples and vanquished and eradicated
the native-born who stood in their way
he's saying all this is good because
Western civilization spread but it did
so in the name of white supremacy
there's only one problem that's not true
okay if you recall a little bit about
your history books Spain Portugal France
Holland in England we're all at war with
was nothing for several hundred years
here all the white people were fighting
each other - so this idea they had this
kind of common white supremacist
attitude is not really true and even if
they were white supremacists in the
sense that they thought they were
superior in a white man's burden Rudyard
Kipling imperialists even if they
thought that
you know even if they believe that the
white man's burden had to do with white
skin that would be them mistaking the
spread of Western civilization for the
spread of their own race that would be a
mistake on their part
and that be attributing the quality of
the of the spread of Western
civilization to the color of skin which
makes no historic sense there are white
people in Europe going thousands of
years back before Western civilization
was ever a thing right after the fall of
the Roman Empire there were there were
white people all over Europe who had
nothing to do with Western civilization
and who were barbarians before Rome came
to Britain Britain was white
it didn't matter as a bunch of
barbarians I mean so this idea that it's
not culture but it's skin color is
really weird also how do you separate
the skin color the caucuses are full of
people from various ethnicities and a
lot of them are not living lifestyles or
have not lived - historically lifestyles
that were embedded with Western culture
that's been true for a long time but
here is Pat Buchanan they believed
European man had a right to rule the
world beginning in the 16th century
Western imperialists ruled much of what
was called the civilized world was not
the British Empire one of the great
civilizing forces in history a
manifestation of British racial
superiority and then he says nor is a
belief in the superiority of one's race
religion tribe and culture unique to the
West
what is unique what is an experiment
without precedent is what we are about
today we have condemned and renounced
the Scarlet sins of the men who made
America and embrace diversity
inclusivity and equality our new America
is a land where all races tribes creeds
and cultures congregate all are treated
equally and all move ever closer to an
equality of results through the regular
redistribution of opportunity wealth and
power we are going to become the first
universal nation all men are created
equal is an ideological statement where
is the scientific or historic proof for
it are we building our utopia on a sand
pile of ideology and hope so notice the
conflation that Buchanan makes here
right the all men are created equal
was an ideal it was an ideological
statement it's also something the
founders considered self-evident what it
meant was man is made in God's image and
has inalienable right that's the next
phrase of the Declaration the founders
did not mean that all people have equal
qualities that of course is not true but
they meant that all human beings are
capable of achieving freedom they didn't
mean culture doesn't matter the founders
obviously didn't believe that but they
did believe
and that's what the principle that was
enshrined in the declaration says that
all human beings are created with equal
value in God's eyes and that means that
they have equal rights in the eyes of
the government or they should have equal
rights in the eyes of the government but
Buchanan conflict that argument with the
argument that the left makes which is
that all people ought to have equal
outcome and then he says a pox on both
their houses basically white people
built civilization and if white people
begin to fade then civilization will
begin to fade as well ok so he is
basically taking the flip side of the
racist argument made by Angela Wray
which is that America is based in racism
and that's why it's evil and it's
inherently in the DNA and Buchanan says
racism is in our DNA and therefore it's
basically good ok that is really not
good stuff that is really not good stuff
and this is how you see the polarization
taking place it's a real negative now
there is some breaking news that I want
to talk about pappi apparently Steve
Eman is out this is what Drudge is now
reporting Steve Banta is out at the
white house
so my former boss over at Breitbart news
I have a lot of thoughts on this many
many a thoughts I'll discuss all of them
in just a second but first you're going
to have to go over to Daily wire calm
and subscribe and I will tell you all
about the breaking news C Bannon being
out at the white house $9.99 a month
gets you a subscription to The Daily
wire and that means that you get the
rest of this show live on video it means
that you get the N Clavin show live on
video it means that you get the Michael
Knowles show live on video if you choose
to watch it later when we upload it we
cut out all the ads here not to listen
to any of the ads and you also get to be
part of the mailbag which we'll be doing
a little bit later today so if you wanna
get your questions answered we'll take
some live questions today on the mailbag
so you can go over to daily we're calm
right now and subscribe also if you want
the annual subscription not only do you
get all of the aforementioned glories
but you also get this the most
incredible of all vessels leftist you're
hot or cold mug it is a tongue we call
it a tumbler instead of a mug so they
don't piss off steven crowder but who
cares it's basically a mug it's a hot or
cold mug it is the greatest thing that
you will ever hold in your hands other
than your own newborn child and
depending on your child maybe greater
than that so this is this particular
vessel is something you must have $99 a
year gets you this and it also gets you
all of the wonderful things that we have
told you about including my show and all
the other shows also if you just want to
listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud we always appreciate it when
you send when you subscribe on iTunes
and leave
to review it helps us in the iTunes
rankings so make sure that you do that
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
all right so Steve Danon is out at the
white house this is the news the
breaking news from The Drudge Report and
Drudge should know because you know
Drudge is very tapped into the
administration so here is the question
what led to this and why now and what's
it going to mean so why now is because
Steve Blum self up so in the last few
months
Bandon has been marginalized by people
ranging from Jared and Ivanka
to General John Kelly Kelly obviously
didn't like Bannen thought Bandhan was a
nefarious force in the White House and
last week Vanden has been the guy at
Trump's elbow and him urging him to to
not disassociate from the alt-right and
to engage with the alt-right over
Charlottesville and then he came out and
he did a really kind of incredible
interview with a magazine called The
American Prospect a leftie magazine
called The American Prospect in which he
ripped on Trump's North Korean policy
talked about globalist like Gary Cohn
what he calls globalist like Gary Cohn
ripped him by name and also suggested
that he was going to get rid of all of
his enemies in the State Department
undermined our foreign policy he it was
a really bad interview and input Trump
in a very awkward position a lot of
people have been calling for abandoned
to oust her because of his closeness to
the alt-right I've said for a year that
Van Daan's closeness to the alt-right
never should have been brought into the
campaign I mean I wrote an op-ed for The
Washington Post August 18th I think
literally one year ago today saying
exactly this that this is a problem for
Trump so Trump is getting rid of him
probably because Kelly wants to get rid
of him not necessarily because Trump
cares Trump also thinks he's a leaker
from things abandoned talks in the media
a lot which is true but the fact that
Trump is the fact that Bannon is gone
could lead to a new and kind of shocking
division inside the conservative
movement remember Bannon is only really
well-liked among a particular alt-right
populist faction he the people like him
in sort of the populist area he's seen
as sort of the go-to guy just as Jeff
Sessions was seen as that at aging but
Bannon has Breitbart at his disposal
Breitbart while I was there and before I
left
turned into Trump Pravda they turned it
into you an outlet that did nothing but
surely Trump and that was under ban and
because Bannon was working with Trump at
the time sort of behind the scenes and
then obviously became one of his
campaign strategists his chief campaign
strategist well now Bannon is gone and
so he's going to go back to Breitbart
and he sort of paved the way for what
he's going to do next he is he's got two
paths here now that he's out right path
number one is that Bannon could
theoretically kind of play it safe keep
it close to the vest
go back to Breitbart keep quiet that's
not bad in saying right Bannon is a ward
guy all the time he likes to shout about
war he talks about military analogies
all the time he's not nearly as
brilliant as people think he is because
he gives off that impression but he's a
smart guy I'm not saying he's stupid but
he's he's not quite the the 40 chess guy
that everybody thinks he is he's a very
instinctive knee jerk knife fighter so
my understanding is that he will
probably go back to Breitbart from his
perch at Breitbart he will launch
attacks on all the quote-unquote
globalists inside the administration
that once you go back to the
administration and you and you won once
you go back to Breitbart and you decide
to rip on Trump this could really open a
rift
so remember Bannon also has the support
of the single biggest donors to the
Republican Party the Mercer family over
in Florida they gave a lot of money to
Trump they gave a lot of data to Trump
they're their firm Cambridge analytical
is Trump's data operation and it's
unclear right now if this is sort of an
amicable parting of ways or whether this
is an open war it's an open war things
are about to get very very interesting
because you could see a situation where
Trump and ban and go right at each other
were banned and decides to use Breitbart
as his club to beat the living crap out
of Trump uses Rebecca Mercer and the
Mercer family as his sort of money bags
to do all of those things starts to lash
Trump from outside as having lost the
support of his base and tears down Trump
the same way the Breitbart build him up
you could easily see that situation
occurring but Breitbart itself is in a
bit of a pickle because so many of their
supporters are Trump supporters so what
happens if Breitbart decides to go to
war with Trump over any of this stuff
if Breitbart decides to go to war they
lose readership and does Bandhan even
care I'm not sure banning cares so we're
about to enter a very interesting period
now where a lot of trumps base may turn
on him for getting rid of Bannen right
after a lot of Trump space fell very
enchanted with him after after what he
had to say about Charles know at least
abandon base so it
going to be fascinating to watch that's
all I can say I you know well we'll have
to see how this proceeds my gut instinct
tells me the sieve man and is not going
to take this lying down
that's not Steve style Steve is a very
transactional fellow so if he thinks
that he will get better get better
results by not attacking Trump then
he'll stay outside and sort of cheerlead
for Trump in sort of late Cory
Lewandowski has after being ousted by
Trump but if he thinks that he is going
to make a career of his own now that
he's famous enough that he can make a
career of his own I'm going to talk
radio we can write books he can he can
run for office himself with the help of
the alt-right he can lead a populist
revolution from the outside because
Trump has abandoned his base then he
could see an open war begin between
Trump and one of the guys who was
supposedly
the intellectual in the trumpism
movement really fascinating development
okay so we'll do a quick thing I like
quick thing I hate them we'll get to the
mailbag because we have a full mailbag
today so things that I like so I have to
admit that I laughed a little bit when I
saw this Chris Cantwell is a really
disgusting white supremacist who was at
this Antipa will act as a white
supremacist rally in Charlottesville and
just talking about what a violent guy he
was over and over - vice news how he was
preparing himself for violence he wanted
violence he liked violence he thought
the violence was good here was Chris
Cantwell - vice news just a few days ago
you can remember Dylan Rose name you can
remember at an air waybill were
incapable in finance a capable of course
we're capable I'm carrying a pistol like
over the gym all the time I'm trying to
make myself more capable of violence
PJ and then he would go on and talk
about how he was looking for the
violence sometimes the violence would be
good he said in a radio interview that
he was going there seeking violence and
then there's a warrant out for his
arrest and here's a tape of him after
the Lord has put out for his arrest I
contacted the local police I called the
Charlottesville Police Department and I
asked them I said I've been told that
there's a warrant out for my arrest and
they they said that they wouldn't
confirm it but that I could find this
out if I excuse me that I could find
this out if I wanted to go to a local
magistrate or something like that but
with everything that's happening I don't
think it's wise for me to be you know
going going
there's a state of emergency the
National artisan or the tough guy crying
into camera over an arrest warrant being
put out for him this guy is an open
white supremacist says that Trump sold
his daughter to a Jew one of the guys
who was chanting Jews will not replace
us really just a stellar fellow who had
openly talked about engaging in violence
and now he's crying openly on camera
does it seem like an emotionally stable
human being be you and put everything
else aside this guy needs help I mean I
actually feel a little bit bad for him
in the sense that I think that I don't
feel bad for him cuz he's a bad person
but I feel bad for him just as a human
being that this guy obviously is
emotionally mentally unstable and the
guy truly needs some help okay time for
a quick thing that I hate in the film
okay so today's thing I hate comes
courtesy of Mark Steyn so I usually like
a lot of what Mark Steyn has to say I
think it's a really really talented
columnist his book on Broadway is
terrific he was on with Tucker Carlson
and he started ripping on the tech
industry you know a lot of these tech
companies had pulled service from some
users and and Stein suggests that the
government needs to get involved I don't
see why if the United States government
thinks in 1918 no not 1980 nothing's
about 10 years before that in 1909
whenever it was that Standard Oil had
gotten too big
if Standard Oil whispered in 1909 yeah
what is Google now and and and there's a
difference the the oil companies or MGM
when they were both made movies and
owned cinemas they're basically in the
movie business
Standard Oil is in the oil business
Google is in the fort business when you
have someone who is actually in control
of ideas who knows the data of just
about all 7 billion people on the planet
and it is enforcing idea an ideological
straightjacket that is far more
disturbing than if a standard oil or MGM
are enforcing ideological straightjacket
so I actually think we're moving into a
very dark era where YouTube and and
Facebook and Twitter will bounce more
and more people off their
monopolist and that will lead to more
volcano so I agree with Stein that a lot
of these technological firms are
engaging in some real nasty kind of
thought policing I agree with all that
but his idea that the government should
get involved I'm on the side of the
government should not be involved in any
of this stuff that if you don't like it
you can go build your own server the
idea the government is going to start
regulating these things means that the
government is now going to have to take
some sort of ownership of these this is
the problem that I have with this is why
mortal libertarian in some of this that
I am a conservative I don't think the
government should be involved in
regulating how private companies do
business I think that's a dangerous
dangerous principle and once you start
doing it it's hard to stop it okay
so let's jump right into the mailbag so
insects been recently there's been
advancements in science in relation to
gene editing and the future possibility
of being able to safely edit people's
genes seems to be getting closer and
closer from religious perspective do you
believe this to be morally correct I
understand we are creations of God but
in examples of curing diseases and such
is it just for us to change ourselves
from the way he has made us so here is a
distinction that well here's a logical
distinction that you can take or leave I
let me put it this way if I had a child
who was going to be and let's say the
process of gene editing did not involve
abortion in any way it was just editing
a gene so you're just fixing a problem
so let's say that my daughter had had a
development where she had a hole in her
heart at six
she's fine she'll be great for the rest
of her lecture with 120 years no problem
she's good as new but let's say that I
had the capacity to cut that out of her
gene you know before she had to go
through a an open-heart surgery what
I've done that you bet your ass I
would've done that the same thing is
true for the tay-sachs gene the same
thing is true for BRCA the the the
cancer gene breast cancer gene to cure
diseases or prevent disease it seems to
me a proper use of gene editing and I
think that's true for blindness I think
that's true for disability I think that
you know did to to to prevent people
from suffering with conditions I think
it's perfectly valid and normal to
enhance however I think you start to get
into the ITT or the territory they're
going to enhance certain people's
intelligence
or you're going to enhance their muscle
power or you're going to change the
color of their eyes or their hair I
think now you're starting to play with
dangerous stuff because once you do that
then you could see a situation where
people are engineering human beings to
be a particular way and we feel that we
are God and we can control how human
beings should be from the time that they
are in it you know created yeah you can
see a very dangerous situation for a
couple of reasons one you could see a
situation where people just decide they
don't want a particular type of human
being so we're just going to breed it
out of the population you can also see a
situation where the people who are very
wealthy can afford gene-editing
and their kids are perfect and you can
see a situation where poor people cannot
and their kids are kind of normal and it
actually exacerbates the the divide in
society I think that these are very very
morally fraught issues but I don't think
it's quite as easy as don't get involved
in gene editing at all Gabriel says hey
Ben greetings from Brazil do you think
the sharp increase in nihilism and
self-hatred in the West has a direct
correlation to our rejection of religion
as Nietzsche predicted yes I do I think
that the rejection of faith in favor of
science has led to the destruction of
both faith and science I discussed this
last week and the big idea but the idea
that that we are free human beings
capable of making decisions the idea
that we have free will and change our
minds the idea that we have moral
responsibility for our actions all of
these things are products of faith not
products of science and science has
actually undermined a lot of these
claims leading to a deterministic
universe that forces you into a sort of
existential nihilism and that's very
dangerous for society
Nicholas does you're been today I got
into an argument with an atheist friend
of mine who believes that telling your
kids that living a sinful life will lead
you to hell is child abuse and will scar
your kids for life I'm not an extremely
religious person but I believe in my
Christian values how do I explain the
morality of teaching kids about sin well
I mean I think there the fact is that
teaching children that certain behavior
is going to lead to an unhappy life both
here and in the hereafter is not child
abuse it's actually a valid warning
number one if you're a person of faith
you don't believe that this is a a
conjecture you believe that this is a
fact right faith believes that that the
idea of heaven or punishment in the
afterlife or come up into the afterlife
is the real thing so it's not like
you're lying your kid this isn't
Claus or Easter or the Easter Bunny
right this is this is actually something
different this is you telling what you
perceive to be a truth to your children
so that's not child to be a second of
all I think that you can make the case
against sin in almost secular terms very
often by simply saying that things that
are sinful lead you down a road that
sullies you as a human being it makes
your life more unhappy there tends to be
an extraordinarily high crossover
between the things that God says are a
sin in judeo-christian system and things
that are actually Nana that end with
nasty results to you in this life as
well and I think that God set out a
system that has created the greatest
civilization the history of mankind I
don't think that's a coincidence Trey
says hey Ben what is your myers-briggs
type I can't remember what is my earth
Briggs is this the introvert thing I'll
have to look it up real fast
oh yeah the free personality test you
know I did it at one point and I cannot
remember for the life of me which one
which type I am I have to look up the
types and I'd probably remember so I
believe that there are let's see so I
know I was an extrovert I know that in
terms of sensing versus intuition I I
think I was a sensing versus intuition I
believe that when it came to making
decisions
I was thinking versus feeling and when
it came to prefer judging versus
perceiving I believed that I was a
judging so I was either an ESTJ or an
ENTJ I believe so
that's for what for whatever that's
worth that's what I think I was anyway I
can't remember to be frank with you okay
joy he says do practice things you still
believe that there is Messiah and why is
there a difference between Jews today
and use of the Old Testament
thanks love your show so yes practicing
Jews believe that there will be a
messiah and when he comes he'll Purser's
he will pursue certain functions you'll
reestablish a temple on the Temple Mount
he will he will be responsible for the
end gathering of exile he will establish
peace in Israel this is according
Maimonides he has basically a very set a
simple set of tasks he's not some sort
of superhuman figure he's not a god come
back to earth or anything like that and
as far as the difference between Jews
today issues of the Old Testament
so Jews of the Old Testament
we're living you know in I mean I the
traditional Orthodox answers there's not
a huge difference but the truth is that
there's been development in Judaism
through the oral torah through the
through the Talmud the rabbinic law has
obviously developed a fair bet since the
Old Testament so there's a lot of stuff
that use do today that's not explicit in
the Old Testament but we feel is
implicit in the Old Testament and so so
Moses may not recognize some of the
practices that we pursue today in
Judaism but the idea in the tomlin
explicitly says this in the talmud is
that moses would come back and he'd be
happy that he doesn't recognize that
because he set up a system of lawmaking
and law giving and we've developed that
system sort of the same way that the
founders might come back and look at a
marathon say well I don't really
understand a lot of this but they'd be
happy with the system that they created
Luke says what do you think of the idea
that automation will one day take over
so many jobs Universal that a universal
basic income might be necessary so as
I've said before I think that it's
possible in the future that automation
may do that but I think that we are a
long way from that right now employment
is nearly full every time there is a an
uptick in technology there's a similar
uptick in jobs of another type I know
that everyone always thinks that we've
reached the end of the industrial Road
people thought that in 1850 with the
Industrial Revolution which is why they
were breaking machines but I don't think
that we've come close to that yet John
says hey Ben at any point in time did
you consider joining the military yeah
actually after law school I considered
whether or not to join Jack one of the
reasons that I didn't join jag at the
time was because as in Orthodox Jew it's
a little bit difficult to be in the
military something the military wouldn't
accommodate it but there are conflicts
religious conflicts in terms of holidays
up and Sabbath off and all this that
conflict a little bit there are a lot of
Jews who do serve in the military there
are Orthodox Jews who just serve in the
military and good for them there's a
group actually that I support called Jay
fam that provides support to Jews who
are in the military so they can do all
of these things and serve in the
military
let's see Jim says hey Ben I would like
to know your thoughts on the new
intentional walk Mormon baseball I
always believed that having to actually
throw the pitches would messes the
pitchers rhythm and therefore add a
readjustment dynamic when facing the
next batter what are your thoughts so I
think I think the rule is stupid this
idea that you just signal and then
somebody goes to first base as opposed
to throwing the four pitches I've
actually seen games where a run there's
man on third and they're intentionally
walking somebody because it's man on
second
third they want to have a force and the
pitcher throws it away in the run scores
so I think that this is a dumb rule and
I don't think the problem with baseball
is the speed of the game I think the
problem is the speed of life now and so
a lot of people don't get it but I was
at Dodger Stadium two nights ago the
place was packed I mean it was it was
just it was packed to the gills every
seat was filled there's still a lot of
interest in baseball it still draws
millions and millions and millions of
people to the ballpark every year the
one role I do like is I do like this
rule the 30 second rule for pitches I
think is good and I think they should
also have rules about how many times
batters can step out of the batter's box
and adjust their gloves and all this
stuff the pitchers have a rule I think
the batter should have a rule too once
you're in the batter's box you get to
step out like once during a nap but you
don't get to step out between every
pitch Jackson says hey Ben do you
believe the earth was formed over six
figurative days or you believe it was
formed in six literal 24-hour days so
Gerald Schroeder is a is a scientist
who's written a book called God and God
science in the Big Bang I think it's
called in which he discusses this one of
the problems with the the literalist
version of it was created in six 24-hour
period is that the Sun was not created
on the first day right the Sun was not
there and so the idea that a day in the
Torah at the beginning means the same
thing today now is kind of an odd
contention here I'll turn to something
really interesting he talked about the
the wavelength of I believe it's it's
the wavelength of a background radiation
in the universe and he talks about how
the universe expands the wavelength of
the background radiation gets longer and
so in fact the number of the number of
waves in a 24-hour day of background
radiation actually equates to the number
of waves that would have been millions
of years before the Big Bang occurred
it's kind of interesting I may be
explaining it poorly you should go read
the book
shailen says once you puppies Katie's
piglets and just hatch baby sea turtles
have in common
um I don't even know what this means or
why this is in the mailbag or what is
going on right now they're all animals
hmm when what is there another ant is
there another answer I'm supposed to be
giving here and there's got to be a main
thing that I'm just not getting anyway
we've reached the end of the week Eve
Bannon is out we will have a lot to talk
about on Monday that is for sure I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]